now some of the people who were rescued
were taken to taken to a number of
shelters around the houston area now the
city's main shelter is at the george r
brown convention center in downtown
houston that's where we were just
yesterday where people are being brought
in on foot and on truckload
these massive city dump trucks served as
rescue vehicles delivering people
plucked from flooded homes and roadways
and how did they get you onto these
trucks
with ladders and we held on for daylight
and you held on and they drove you
through the flood waters here right
exactly
this is at least the fourth dump truck
here
and as you can see people are just
coming out
being led down
ladders and even carried off
once inside the red cross helps them get
situated with a hot meal and dry clothes
i lost everything cars
i lost a couple vehicles
my whole apartment is flooded the people
who have been coming are coming in with
very small trash bags sometimes nothing
sometimes just wrapped in a towel betsy
robertson is with the american red cross
supplies are here more are coming
and we just really want to make sure
that everybody here has what they need
the patel family spent the night here
after being rescued from their flooded
neighborhood by a coast guard helicopter
how did the coast guard know where to
find you well i had an umbrella and a
white t-shirt and i was just flagging
them freda ben bowie and her sister who
is nine months pregnant were lifted to
safety by the coast guard too before
being brought to the shelter with a
handful of belongings the coast guard is
amazing they're like
the coast guard i don't know
i know true heroes true heroes
gail it was really unbelievable to talk
to some of the people who had been
brought in they were wet they were cold
they were glad to be indoors the red
cross really doing an amazing job
they're shutting up setting up a mega
shelter in dallas because there are
thousands of people who need a place to
stay their homes have been flooded they
have nothing left the sun is going to
rise here in about 45 minutes and i
think that's going to bring a new wave
of understanding about the destruction
that harvey has brought to people here
and also more need for more rescues
we'll have more coming up but gail i'll
send it back to you well nora i know you
are a texas girl we saw the one of the
gentlemen say listen it's the spirit of
texas coming out and it's clear you're
seeing a lot of that spirit just in the
short time that you've been there
i'm glad you mentioned that gail because
it is friends helping friend while you
may think people are helpless they're
actually helping one another every
chance they can get that's right people
who need help for helping others thanks
a lot norah we'll see you in a couple
seconds